foreign
we're going to talk about something that
isn't related to the to the broader
American economy children's books
specifically we're going to talk about
weird children's fantasy novels by the
author Roald Dahl which were recently
subject to edits by sensitivity readers
there were words removed phrases changed
in some cases whole sentence is added to
make doll's work supposedly less
offensive obviously I'm going to call
this segment the horse you rolled in on
doll of course is the famous author of
uh books like Matilda James the giant
peach he died decades ago and his works
are now owned by the road doll
publishing Group which in 2021 announced
they would proceed with a number of
adaptations on Netflix this year doll's
publisher Puffin books worked with an
outside consultant a group called
inclusive Minds to make changes to the
text of his book the edited versions uh
removed words like fat ugly and crazy in
other cases small details were changed
in the witches for example women
characters were who were became top
scientists and business owners
previously they had been cashiers in a
supermarket the edits made
gender-specific terms gender neutral
they omitted references to mothers and
fathers and in general focused on
descriptions related to weight gender
race and ethnicity Robbie I know you
have written and uh and thought an awful
lot about these issues um this is just
the latest example of so-called
sensitivity readers
um being brought in to edit Works
intended for young readers give us some
background here just ground Us in what's
going on how pervasive is this how does
it play out behind the scenes does it
worry you
uh it worries me greatly and it it also
worried Roald Dahl himself I want to uh
Rita to you a quote from him he said
this I've warned my Publishers that if
they later on so much as changed a
single comma in one of my books they
will never see another word for me never
ever and he said when I am gone if that
happens then I'll wish Mighty Thor
knocks very hard on their heads with his
mjolnir that's the hammer if you've seen
the the Marvel movies I've seen them all
I assume the statement was made before
the Marvel movie or he yes or he says I
will send along The Enormous Crocodile
to gobble them up this is the Fate Roald
Dahl thought should uh should await the
sensors of his material um how would the
sensitivity readers rewrite that
a uh can we say enormous uh because we
can't say fat so maybe we can't say
enormous a hefty crocodile a crocodile
of size how about that
um so this is this problem with the
sensitivity readers really is quite
pernicious so many uh new writers Young
Writers are subjected to this ridiculous
group of people who purport to have
expertise pertaining to Identity race
gender sexuality Etc
um but oftentimes they have no expertise
whatsoever they just they just happen to
fit that category Kat Rosenfeld is a
wonderful writer she's a writer of young
adult fiction she also writes for reason
on occasion and she had a great piece
for us on this I'm describing the plight
of this young author who is writing a
book about an African-American man who
had been formerly incarcerated or
prosecuted just fiction book trying to
uh make it at a university and the
author was assumed to be black but it
turned out he was Filipino so the
publisher at the last minute was like
wait wait you're not black okay we have
to have someone who's black read this
book then and they got like a lady who
was British uh who was black but like
she has no understanding of an
incarcerated young African-American
adult uh it makes no sense to have her
weighing in on on this and this is what
awaits so many authors now is having
these people who for totally surface
reasons supposedly should be able to
weigh in on this Lionel Shriver another
author who has written for reasonably
you Catherine you did a great interview
with her a while back author of the book
uh what to do uh we need to talk about
Kevin that was what it's called she has
written so persuasively I think about
why this is a bad thing for free
expression for for intellectual
diversity uh forcing authors to only
narrowly write about their own
experience I mean that's a that's an
attack on the very idea of writing and
journalism and all of it you're supposed
to persuasively write uh about other
people's experiences with some knowledge
of course if you do a bad job of it you
should be criticized but that should be
up to the authors not these not these
sensitivity readers even more than that
I think it it's an attack on empathy
it's an attack on the idea that you can
under that someone can understand and
experience that is not their own my
favorite story about sensitivity readers
was the guy who worked as a sensitivity
reader for a publication for a
publishing house and then he of course
wrote his own young adult fiction novel
which got unpublished because of
sensitivity readers who said no no you
can't publish this uh so Nick I I want
to ask you here this is the the thing
where I sometimes struggle with this
issue as a Libertarian we have seen
authors like Salman Rushdie call this uh
called the called the world doll at its
censorship we've seen a general outcry
about this sort of editing but this is a
private company making changes to Works
where it owns the rights I understand
the argument I I in fact you know I like
in some ways like I buy the argument
that it is a kind of censorship but also
isn't it just a byproduct of property
rights being passed down over the years
I mean sometimes the guy down the block
is going to build an ugly Edition on his
house and it's going to really make the
neighborhood look terrible do you think
this is fundamentally different I don't
think we're supposed to say ugly anymore
people yeah yeah I also want to as I
always do because I'm a role doll hater
from way back I want to point out that
he is a raging anti-semite and it's kind
of fascinating that this latest turn of
events has kind of taken the light off
of that but he if Robbie was quoting
from him here's a quote that he said
um there's a trait in the Jewish
character that does provoke animosity I
mean there's always a reason why
anti-anything crops up anywhere even a
stinker like Hitler didn't just pick on
them for no reason
um so and that that came out that came
out in the 90s I mean it was a rolled
out by his own account was a
tremendously awful human being and it
doesn't change what's happening here
which is screwed up uh and I think is is
not wrong because you're right this is
his literary estate in the same way that
Dr Seuss is literacy can do whatever
they want including not publishing
things I think what is particularly
disturbing about this is It's really
memory holding stuff and Cat Rosenfield
again who Robbie mentioned wrote a great
essay for us about this and what there
are stealth edits you know we we've
written about the 1619 project where
mistakes or changes get made without
anybody knowing this kind of thing
happens it happened uh you know
ironically to Ray Bradbury the author of
Fahrenheit 451 the version of that book
that most of us probably read if you
grew up in the 70s uh was a boulderized
Edition that he didn't know that his
publisher changed words in it to make it
more palatable for high school audiences
specifically for school children yeah
and he flipped out when he heard that
and he made Valentine you know publish
the actual book uh when he found out
about it and what's interesting here and
again this isn't a a direct
contradiction of what we're talking
about here but when you as we shift to
electronic media and Kat Rosenfeld has
talked about this we you don't actually
own the media in the same way it's one
thing if you downloaded a song file onto
your computer but if you're reading it
through Kindle or through a variety of
other things you are licensing the right
or you're buying a license to read that
through that but Amazon owns it and
Amazon actually can completely vaporize
your collection of Works they can change
things and update texts with all sorts
of things without telling you and Cat
Rosenfeld has talked I think very
persuasively about this that that may or
may not be a good idea in any given
circumstance but the fact that we're not
aware of it or thinking about it or
noting it is troubling because you know
this without going full or well or a
full Bradberry you know it's it's a good
idea to understand the editing process
because we're constantly revising
ourselves the stories we tell about
ourselves the stories that we share with
our children Etc and one of the issues
here is that it's not just that books
are being censored or edited after the
fact it's that authors uh are are
self-censoring and there is a chilling
effect here in in which authors feel
like they can't write about certain type
topics they can't write in certain ways
Catherine I actually want to ask you the
mom question now we're gonna be like
that did get there eventually you have
kids in the uh target age range for Road
doll books right so how do you think
about this as a parent are sensitivity
readers actually protecting kids from
anything because I just recall
sensitivity readers weren't a thing when
I was a kid but but like censorious
Librarians and parents were and there
were various adult authority figures
that tried to hide Asia inappropriate
material from me stuff that I really
should not have been reading and I will
tell you it did not work at all
so I actually think one of the best ways
for kids to encounter troubling ideas is
through the veil of fiction I think that
when you're you know when you're
processing something new that is scary
I know I learned a lot of things that I
wasn't quite ready to think about as
real in the context of particularly the
kind of fiction that rolls all right
it's like the ridiculous the Absurd this
isn't this isn't waiting for me under my
bed or is it and that I I think that
taking that away from kids is is
probably a mistake but of course taking
things away from kids is really always
just the thin end of the wedge for
taking it away from adults